bonjour christophe barret
bonjour merci beaucoup d'action directe
bonjour merci d'être en direct ce matin
avec mon sur rt france comment est-ce
que vous analysez cette volonté du parti
bob de supprimer l'aïd el kébir du
calendrier des fêtes musulmanes au
profit d'une d'une fête chrétienne
santhiaba ce cas il est en campagne et
puis cette proposition qui a été faite
et elle a été fait donc au parlement
ceuta par une députée nationale de boxe
qui est aussi localement implantés et
qui donc que vous l'avez dit cherche à
remplacer une fête par une autre c'est
curieux parce que tous les ans bien sûr
le parlement sous la botte le calendrier
des fêtes et jours fériés il s'agit de
voter celui de 2022 pour les calendriers
précédent vote n'avait jamais rien dit
la moitié de la population de 70 et 85
mille habitants de ceuta et musulmane
donc comme dans tous les villages
espagnols est une fête religieuse qui
donne lieu à des réjouissances pendant
plusieurs jours là c'est vrai qu'ils y
ont il était prévu de donner aux
musulmans une une fête supplémentaires
dans le calendrier en 2022 noël tombe un
dimanche donc ça faisait qu' il y avait
finalement un jour férié qui étaient
disponibles on avait décidé d'attribuer
aux musulmans il a suffi de cela pour
que box monte sur ses grands chevaux on
voit là qu'on est dans un processus de
radicalisation du mouvement bien sûr
dans la perspective de prochaines
élections ou pour lesquels on dit que
vox pour être entré au gouvernement avec
le parti populaire avec la droite et et
cette fête religieuse de l'aïd el kébir
à ceuta on sait à une ampleur
particulière elle est ancrée depuis
depuis longtemps elle fait partie de
l'identité de la commune ah oui tout à
fait et d'ailleurs c'est vrai que le
parti populaire avec quito gouvernement
de ceuta qui gouvernent ceuta avait eu
maille à partir avec vox vox intéressant
parce qu'il avait il a gagné les
législatives à ceuta la députée somme
talent elle et c'est une députée boxe
mais il avait perdu les municipales vous
voyez c'est comme dans l'indépendantisme
en catalogne alors oui il ya parfois des
résultats différents des aux élections
niveau local au niveau national au
niveau national les habitants de
certains ont été plutôt vindicatif avec
cette peur de lui mende immigration
incontrôlée qui était donc
instrumentalisés par le maroc à un
moment et puis finalement il veut pris
au quotidien il préfère quand même voter
pour une droite modérée
cette droite qui se fait accuser donc
d'être de favoriser l'islam de abascal
devait accuser les musulmans de ceuta
qui sont dans les plus anciennes ces
bouteilles espagnole depuis moyen-âge a
donc deux d'être la cinquième colonne du
maroc on est dans une logique un petit
peu de deux guerres civiles de violon
d'imposition d'une violence verbale
alors on est pas on n'est pas retourner
à la guerre civile il n'y a pas de
violence physique de la rue encore que
il ya des magnifiques et une
manifestation fasciste à madrid quand
même avec des bras levés mais il ya
cette volonté surtout de sentiers -
pascal d'apparaître comme le parce que
pablo iglesias appelle le leader de
podemos qui s'est retiré de la vie
politique mais qui a justement fait
produit son premier article de presse
sur ce sujet là sur le risque d'un
gouvernement d'une entrée l'extrême
droite au gouvernement pas vu abascal il
veut être yves incarner l'espagne
l'isthme réactionnaire c'est à dire on
commence par on vivait mieux du temps le
compo pour ensuite imposer toutes les
thèses de l'extrême droite jusqu'aux
plus rance santiago abascal qui est qui
accuse les députés autonome musulmans de
l'enclavé de ceuta d'être trop pro
marocain est ce que c'est fondé selon fu
pas mon propre alpes où il n'y a pas eu
de ya pas eu de déclaration de loyauté
des détenus marocains de ceuta
simplement on sait ce qui s'est passé
l'été dernier et 1 milliards le le
gouvernement marocain dont dans le cadre
du grand jeu diplomatique avec le
moyen-orient avec l'afrique du nord a
voulu faire pression sur l'espagne en
main en rétorsion de l'accueil on ne sai
gon savez de d'un leader la leader du
front polisario via l'algérie en espagne
on était dans le cadre des relations
diplomatiques et d'expression l'heure
c'est vrai pas très pas acceptable pour
l'union européenne et pour les
démocraties on n'était pas dans c'est
pas la grande invasion qui commence est
du reste beaucoup de si mais quand on
était rendu au maroc dans des conditions
un peu
illégal parfois contesté en tout cas par
certaines associations qui défendent les
droits de l'homme donc voilà on est on
est dans un domaine dans le cadre d'une
campagne nationale il s'est passé
quelque chose de fondamental il ya
quelques mois dans la politique
espagnole c'est l'écroulement du parti
du centre et dont vous avez à droite
pour incarner la droite espagnole a plus
que deux parties la droite et l'extrême
droite y appuie le centre donc sentir
voir santiago à sky qui a essayé qui a
essayé de faire voter une motion de
censure ou par le mot congrès de madrid
qui n'a pas réussi qui est un petit peu
le vent en poupe parce que il c'est lui
qui a fait vous en avez peut-être parler
qui a faits et a porté l affaire du
confinement devant tribunal
constitutionnel et puis qui a gagné pas
sur le fond mais sur la forme le
gouvernement espagnol n'aurait pas dû
imposer de confinement comme il l'a fait
sans club basque à lille et dans une
démarche où l'inflation verbale pour
créer le vide autour de lui faire en
sorte qu' il n'y a donc que d'apparaître
comme le principal opposant ce que la
droite ne le sud la droite ne sera pas
forcément elle est capable de le prendre
au gouvernement au pouvoir avec elle
parce que c' est l' expo droite en
espagne est traditionnellement une
émanation de de la droite et qui a pas
deux il n'y a pas de cordon sanitaire
comme comme chez nous mais 7,7 droit
times elle va pas suivre être sûr à paal
box jusqu'au bout la droite essayé de
lancer une pétition contre par exemple
l'amnistié offerte aux
politiques et aux politiques prisonniers
catalans aux indépendantistes catalans
qui ont été remis en liberté ce qui
avait été condamnée qui ont été remis en
liberté par le gouvernement socialiste
la droite a dû s'arrêter arrêtez de
faire signer c'est une pétition qui
avait été lancée dans l'opinion publique
espagnole alors que vox est toujours
vent debout contre cette décision on est
dans la surenchère parce qu'on est dans
une période préélectorale qui donnent la
majorité peut être de 175 députés plus à
la droite et à l'extrême droite et la
basse qu'elle peut faire le vide autour
de lui mais
il est possible que cette affaire de ces
menaces se finisse par par parvenir par
un parent non lieu ça fume se finisse
par un
statu quo à dire voilà le
guen sera pas changée
le lendemain de noël restera en 2022
parce que là elle est un dimanche une
fête
le cred chrétienne et puis il y aura
tout de même c'est à cet avis qui est
déjà très décriée déjà depuis longtemps
dans le calendrier local puisque bien
sûr on est vous l'avez rappelé 1 c'est
une enclave espagnole en afrique du nord
donc la population est musulmane voilà
justement pour conclure en quelques mots
est ce que cette affaire de ceuta cette
suppression de fait nul du mal qu'elle
est qu elle a dans la population
espagnole est ce que est ce que ça
divise
on en parle très peu ce qu'ils fuyaient
qu'impressionnant beaucoup donc c'est la
manifestation vraiment fasciste avec des
bras levés des insultes pour les gens
qui n'ont pas la peau blanche pour les
homosexuels dans les rues de madrid
santiago abascal 100 des cent mais c'en
est un petit peu éloigné le seul
ministère qui réagit à cette à cette
manifestation c'est le ministère de
l'égalité qui a donc porté plainte pour
incitation à la haine c'est surtout ces
affaires là voilà deux qui se passerait
maintenant un petit peu la violence de
rue et puis vous savez que l'opinion
publique est complètement centre et là
sur ce qui se passe un peu plus au sud
dans les îles canaries avec cette
éruption volcanique ont beau là tous les
élèves l'épiphénomène de 2,2 du
calendrier religieux de ceuta leva va
probablement disparaître des écrans
radars jusqu'à jusqu'à la prochaine
provocation de dabas cannes une vie que
de cela et on en reparlera merci
beaucoup en tout cas christophe barret
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct sur arte france